planter des arbres le long des cours
d'eau en milieu agricole ça peut
représenter beaucoup de travail pour des
agriculteurs qui n'en manquent pas
vraiment mais quand des jeunes
débarquent par dizaines sur une ferme
pour mettre en terre des arbres
fruitiers d'autres végétaux ça donne un
sérieux coup de main
[Musique]
on est en train de placer les photos
pour les jeunes tu as identifié les
sites ou ce qu'ils vont pouvoir planter
les arbres
Audrey Beaumont Drouin prépare le
terrain des dizaines d'arbres seront
plantés aujourd'hui sur la terre
agricole de son père
en agriculture aménage des îlots de
biodiversité en milieu agricole chez des
producteurs de sa région ceux qui
veulent bien l'accueillir
aussi
à me rapporter des oiseaux
qui vont venir planter
les arbres on travaille 60 70 heures par
semaine mais il faut avoir ça en plus là
c'est
c'est trop
ruisseaux verbalisés ce qui passe sur ma
terre que ça n'a fait des bonnes
riveraines c'est justement des idées de
les accompagner là-dedans qui ont besoin
pour aller me chercher les nutriments
que les cultures annuelles réussiront
pas à aller chercher donc c'est en bonne
Riven ils savent carrément de filtre aux
nutriments avant que c'est aussi se
retrouvent dans l'eau
ça va aider à la qualité de l'eau puis
ils vont faire de l'ombre dans le
ruisseau ce qui va aider à diminuer la
température de l'eau puis on sait qu'il
en la température de l'eau est chaude
c'est là que les algues prolifèrent
audrey est responsable du volet
agriculture au conseil de bassin versant
de la rivière Etchemin c'est elle qui a
eu l'idée ce projet d'assainissement de
bandes
en parler à leur famille et c'est super
constructif pour eux
parce que ça nous permet de respirer
c'est sûr que ça va aider la nature ça
veut dire les petits oiseaux quand ils
vont venir manger les les fruits et les
arbres faire et voilà
audrey a choisi avec soin des essences
d'arbres et de végétaux qui sont plantés
aujourd'hui aux abords des cours d'eau
ou dans les îlots de terre non
cultivables on a essayé de faire des
plantations pour que la pollinisation de
la floraison soit décalée durant l'été
donc
d'apporter une diversité dans l'assiette
des abeilles ça a fait des abeilles qui
sont un peu plus capables de survivre
durant l'hiver qui sont plus plus fortes
[Musique]
se diversification là va servir aussi à
d'autres animaux c'est sûr que les
petits oiseaux vont préférer les arbres
à fruits mais mettons les rollers puis
les espèces à fourrure vont aimer les
conifères pour aller se cacher puis
faire leur nid donc ça leur fait des
corridors pour se déplacer pour aller
d'une station nourricière à l'autre bah
ouais
les jeunes ont même fabriqué des
nichoirs qui pourraient favoriser le
retour d'oiseaux champêtre comme les
hirondelles Charles était exprès en ce
moment sont en déclin les hirondelles à
cause des produits chimiques à cause
justement qu'on coupe on enlève des
habitats mais ici on leur rajoute un
habitat puis la les oiseaux champêtres
on les apprécie vraiment beaucoup nous
les agriculteurs parce que ça mange les
bébés qui eux mangent nos cultures et
avec la déforestation je trouve que
c'est important de faire des nouvelles
habitudes pour les oiseaux
[Musique]
Audrey et son conseil de bassin versant
espère convaincre d'ici deux ans une
cinquantaine d'agriculteurs de leur
région pour l'instant nous la réponse
est vraiment positive de la part des
producteurs le même que je j'ai besoin
d'autres écoles plus de jeunes qui
fabriquent des cabanes qui viennent
tenter des arbres de quoi tu es le plus
fier aujourd'hui d'avoir mis des
nichoirs dans les arbres ça va les
rassurer aussi par rapport à leur avenir
il y a des choses qui sont possibles
encore de faire
sur une ferme puis ça donne une autre
vocation que seulement celle de produire
de préserver pour les autres générations
moi j'étais pas contente qu'ici il me
permet aussi de faire des erreurs chez
eux comme ça je leur ferai pas chez les
autres producteurs